[Music]
we all have those games the ones forever
etched into our memory no matter how far
in the past you need look you can recall
exactly when and where you acquired it
the setting you played it in and the
sensations you felt as its sights and
sounds washed over you for the first
time Final Fantasy 7 is one of those
games for me and because it's so near
and dear the initial announcement of
Final Fantasy 7 remake in 2015 left me
with mixed emotions I was happy Square
Enix was finally giving it a serious go
but all I could think about were the
things I expected to get cut or
potentially worse disfigured by the
norms of modern game design keep the
classics classic I thought nearly four
years later playing Final Fantasy 7
remake at this year's e3 I finally
confronted the things that worried me
the most real-time action taking place
of turn-based combat voice actors
speaking four main characters and a 3d
camera system in place of fixed
perspectives I walked out of the demo
completely surprised not by the sweeping
changes but by my shift and mindset I
naively thought I wanted a conservative
remake of the game I remember but it
turns out the reimagined Final Fantasy 7
is giving me the best gift of all a
chance to fall in love with the world
and characters all over again and
potentially for new reasons it would be
far too premature to claim that the
final product will be as amazing as my
demo but at the risk of sounding naive
once again I'm given hope as I recall
the experience I had when I first played
the original PlayStation demo in 1996
and how that experience carried over to
the full game stepping into a dingy
mockery actor one of the many beating
hearts of the corporate run operation
that saps cells and profits off the
Earth's natural resources two
powerhouses clash cloud a cold-hearted
former super soldier of the Shinra power
company is just there to do a job Barret
the hulking environmental activist
behind the mission to destroy the
reactor has no choice but to work with
cloud to glean from his experience at
Shinra but as a person who wears his
heart on his sleeve and fights for a
noble cause
Barrett's contempt for cloud
self-centered opportunism is loud and
clear the to grit their teeth through
the tension after a few spats and lay
down their explosives their escape
though is cut short by a massive Crimson
mech the Scorpion Sentinel using a
little magic clouds massive sword and a
Gatling gun surgically grafted to
Barrett's arm that never runs out of
ammo the to overcome their opponent in a
calm
their mission inflicting a massive blow
to Shannara when a reactor ultimately
explodes from within core components of
Final Fantasy 7 have undergone massive
transformations but these Afra mention
beats the events that made my first
taste of Final Fantasy 7 so memorable
the first time around have returned to
center stage under a brand new high-def
spotlight the attention to visual
details from the environment to special
effects in combat gives everything a
dreamlike quality almost as if I'm
seeing my imaginary version of Final
Fantasy 7 brought to life I only have
good things to say about the way the
remake looks and my mind runs wild when
I consider what the rest of the game
will look like in the years to come I
was equally impressed by the new
real-time combat system during my brief
stint playing the remake which I did not
see coming rather than standing orderly
on opposite sides of a rectangular
battlefield as before every character
involved in a fight can now run in any
direction at will the ATB gauge is back
but you needn't wait for it to fill up
if you want to throw out basic attacks
which conveniently speed up the refill
process - you only have to wait for a
full ETB gauge to do something more
substantial like cast a spell or use an
ability and if you want a taste of the
past or simply need to catch your breath
you can also bring combat to a halt
while picking commands from menus this
process is somewhat optional as your
allies are controlled by AI when they
aren't given explicit instructions but
it's definitely handy I do still have
questions about the finer points of
materia management the items that govern
what a character is capable of beyond
simply attacking and using items and
time will tell how exciting battles
remain in the long run but it seems like
it will strike a good balance between a
free-flowing action and mini based
mechanics from the past the Scorpion
Sentinel boss as seasoned players will
recall has a tail equipped with a
powerful laser that's best avoided in
the past you would only bear the brunt
of it if you attack the scorpion while
its tail was raised that laser is still
dangerous but it's guaranteed to attack
in the remakes version of this fight
once the tail goes up that's your cue to
run and take cover behind debris strewn
around the reactor platform this
occasional threat along with the
scorpions leap in smash attack lends a
new kick to the familiar foe my hope is
that this is also setting the tone for
the rest of the game and that
positioning will become a critical
component of combat moving forward
juggling priorities was a treat rather
than a hassle thanks to the largely
intuitive controls so the ongoing
challenge would be most welcome win
Final Fantasy 7 remake ultimately
releases in March 2020 I'll be turning
35 years old I've changed a great deal
since my first exposure to Cloud Barrett
and the
rest of the game an e3 demo reminded me
that my relationship to Final Fantasy 7
is actually a holdover from the past
with that mines and the overall quality
of the new demo
I can't wait to rekindle my connection
to one of my favorite games of all time
I feel silly in retrospect for being so
fixated on what Final Fantasy 7 was
rather than what it could be and now I'm
more excited than ever to find out I'll
always have the original if I need it
but this new version is shaping up to be
an enlightening trip down memory lane
[Music]
you